the opening scene features an american
guy named Kyle LeBlanc who works
overseas in a steel mill in magnitogorsh
Russia one day he receives a call from
his wife gray who complains that he
doesn't give enough time for her as a
result Kyle plans to take a few days off
from work so that he can spend some
quality time with her the same evening
Kyle drives back home and on his way he
calls his wife to inform her about his
visit however things take an unexpected
turn when he hears his wife's screaming
voice on the phone it turns out that a
guy named Sergio kovis is broken into
the house and is subjecting gray to
physical assaults Kyle speeds home but
it's too late as he finds his wife's
lifeless body on the sofa while mourning
the loss Sergio attacks him from behind
and flees Kyle angrily pursues him on
the streets of magnitogorshk and gets
into a brawl however they are soon
apprehended by the police in the next
scene both the guys are presented to the
court but Sergio buys the judge and is
declared not guilty due to lack of
evidence enraged by this unjust verdict
Kyle takes drastic action by stealing a
gun from a bailiff and shooting Sergio
multiple times in front of the entire
Courthouse as an act of Revenge for this
crime he is sentenced to life
imprisonment without the possibility of
Parole in the aftermath Kyle along with
some criminals are taken to kravavi
prison which is run by a corrupt Ward
named General krushkov after they arrive
they're forced to surrender their
belongings but Kyle is hesitant to give
up his wedding ring as a result he is
beaten up by an officer named Lieutenant
tolik who then forcibly takes the ring
later that night Kyle Witnesses some
prison guards taking a fellow American
inmate named Billy Cooper to another
cell there he is assaulted by Andre a
prison fighter and member of the Russian
mafia it is evident that this guy has
bribed the officers the following Dawn
the guards escort a bruised and
traumatized Billy to the infirmary while
Andre nonchalantly joins the other
inmates acting as if nothing happened as
the inmates walk in a line Andre taunts
Kyle by reminding him of his wife this
provokes Kyle's anger resulting in a
physical altercation between the two as
a con consequence Kyle is locked up in a
filthy solitary confinement after
enduring several days there he initiates
a hunger strike and subsequently
attempts to commit the unthinkable
however at the last moment he remembers
the lovely moments spent with his wife
prompting him to realize that he must
survive why some days later Kyle is
transferred to a cell alongside inmate
451 an African-American prisoner who is
known to have killed three of his
previous cell mates Kyle is somewhat
scared by his soulmate's reputation but
he doesn't utter a word one day Kyle's
brother-in-law visits him in the prison
and reveals that gray was buried
respectfully he also promises that he is
doing his best to get Kyle out of the
prison but until that time He suggests
Kyle pays some money to the guards so
that they'll make his life easier the
following day Kyle meets Billy in the
prison yard and they engage in
conversation the latter explains that he
is serving 18 months for driving wilst
intoxicated and crashing into a
restaurant everyone craves Greece after
they've had a few but that's on another
level their conversation is interrupted
when they are approached by another
American inmate named Malachi who is
confined to a wheelchair he explains the
politics of the prison and the various
gangs within including the Russian
mafia's alliance with the prison guards
as time passes by Kyle begins to settle
in though Andre continues to taunt him
provoking him to fight during one night
Kyle dreams of his wife being attacked
by Sergio a nightmare that agitates him
in his sleep causing him to breathe
heavily this disturbs his cellmate who
nearly chokes him following this event
Kyle tries to bribe the guards to change
his self but since he is an American the
guards demand more money the scene then
shifts to a few days later showing a
fight event organized within the prison
Malachi informs Kyle the general
khrushkov arranges these matches and
gambles by betting his money on the
fighters Andre who is the only
undefeated guy brutally beats up an
inmate as usual amidst this Kyle asks
Malachi about whether inmate 451 ever
fights to which he answers in the
negative however the prison officials
make a lot of money by putting other
inmates in his cell and then
entertaining their requests to shift at
crevavi prisoners are additionally
tasked with labor-intensive work during
one of these tasks some of the gang
members decide to play a dirty trick on
Kyle they falsely claim that he was
verbally abusing them and the officers
grant them permission to take back their
respect as a result the gang members
beat Kyle up brutally before the guards
send him back to the same solitary cell
in this cell he constantly hears the
disturbing sound of another inmate from
the next cell despite this he can do
nothing but bang on the walls stop
beating off in there Timo shove after a
month Kyle is released from solitary
confinement and now his appearance has
changed due to substantial hair and
beard growth while sharing a meal with
fellow inmates Andre approaches Kyle and
begins taunting him as usual this causes
Kyle to lose his temper and as a result
another brawl ensues between them
shortly after the prison guards
intervene and Kyle is again sent back to
the same solitary cell in the following
days the situation within the prison
starts to get intense as the gangs pick
up fights against each other and kill
other inmates over minor conflicts on a
a particular day at the work site the
prison guards are hit by a land mine
taking advantage of this distraction
Billy along with another inmate decide
to escape the prison but their effort
turns out to be futile the other inmate
is promptly shot while Billy is
recaptured in the midst of all this Kyle
who is constantly bullied by Andre and
his goons begins training himself
intensively later as another fight is
arranged Kyle faces Andre the latter
being the stronger of the two
immediately starts pummeling our hero
however Kyle astonishes the onlookers by
making an unexpected comeback he
gruesomely bites a large chunk from
Andre's neck and kills him in agony in
the aftermath Kyle suffers a mental
breakdown as the prisoners and guards
watch in horror this fight proves to be
a turning point in his life so he gains
the confidence he always lacked Kyle
continuously fights other prisoners and
maintains a winning streak he eventually
becomes hardened by his environment
while also gaining respect his fights
turn increasingly vicious as he even
starts to kill his adversaries moreover
he denied is any help from his
brother-in-law or the American Embassy
feeling that nothing will change Kyle's
changing attitude worries his
well-wishers Malachi and Billy at one
point four five one asks him do you even
know who you are do which 451 answers
himself probably
on the Russian Independence Day Billy
fed up with the physical abuse he
endures makes another attempt to escape
however this time he is betrayed by
Malachi who leaks the information about
his escape to the guards in exchange for
specific medical attention and treatment
after being caught Billy is locked up in
a cell with a prisoner fighter named
Valia the latter is eager to Feast upon
his youthful body in order to retaliate
Billy spits on his face but this only
enrages valya who then beats him up
within an inch of his life the next
morning Kyle spots Billy taking his last
breath before he dies he advises Kyle
not to let the prison guards or inmates
change him into something he is not
moved by these words Kyle realizes that
he now should fight another battle for
his inner peace and ReDiscover his true
self hence he refrains to make the
Resolute decision to refrain from
further fights a choice that infuriates
the prison guards in response they
subject him to punishment by hanging him
outside despite having to face the harsh
weather conditions Kyle refuses to give
up on the other hand inmate 451 learns
of Malachi's treachery against Billy so
he opted to avenge his death he douses
Malachi in a flammable liquid and sets
him on fire resulting in a gruesome
death as he watches Malachi burn 451
reflects on his own traumatic past of
childhood abuse and molestation by a
teacher here it is revealed that he took
Revenge by burning his teacher to death
which is how he ended up in prison why
did Malachi deserve it though inspired
by Kyle's enduring bravery and
resilience during his long punishment
the prison gangs decide to put aside
their rivalries and unite they
collectively refuse to fight against
each other despite the General's orders
this leaves the prison officers
powerless as punishing all the inmates
isn't possible the situation frustrates
General Khrushchev and his fellow
soldiers as they used to make a lot of
money from gambling in the fights but if
everyone bet on Kyle how'd they make
money they hold Kyle responsible for
making the prisoners rebellious and as a
result they devise a plan to get rid of
him in order to settle things down prior
to that Kyle is released from his
restraints and is transferred to the
infirmary for Recovery during this
period he experiences a vision of his
late wife who expresses her happiness
that he has rediscovered his true self
Kyle says that he missed her to which
gray replies that nobody is ever gone as
long as there is someone to remember
them later in his cell block Kyle is
confronted by General khrushoff who is
frustrated at his authority being
challenged he forces Kyle to have one
last fight and the opponent is miloc a
gargantuan prisoner kept separate from
the general population miloc is the same
individual whose voice Kyle kept hearing
through the walls during his time in
solitary confinement the guy's arms are
massive from beating off as the fight
begins our hero is tossed around like a
ragdoll but just as he is about to be
killed he starts banging on a door the
same way he did in confinement this
prompts miloc to recognize Kyle and he
hugs him as a friend miloc
affectionately says that Kyle was the
only one who tried to communicate with
him in All Those Years unfortunately
this further enrages the officers so
Lieutenant holig points his gun at them
ordering them to continue fighting Kyle
refuses and asks the officers to kill
him instead stating that he will not
fight anymore tolik reddies himself to
shoot Kyle but miloc intervenes
launching an assault on the officers
after witnessing this the prisoners
begin to protest turning the tables on
the guards while miloc fights the prison
guards Kyle frees the other prisoners
from their cells igniting a full-scale
riot amidst this commotion miloc is
fatally shot and Kyle Comforts him
before he succumbs to his wounds before
long the prison officers regain control
over the situation by summoning extra
Force ordering the prisoners to retreat
to their cells as Kyle and 451 sit
together Kyle shares about the incident
that happened with his wife and how he
ended up in the prison after hearing his
story 451 tells him that he can help him
in Escaping The Prison following this
the two returned to their cell where 451
hands Kyle the documents that contain
evidence of all the murders and
Corruption that has happened in kravavi
prison for over 20 years he urges Kyle
to expose this information to the U.S
governments and the latter agree for the
prison break 451 asks Kyle to fight for
one last time so that the officer's
attention will stay diverted Kyle is
hesitant about the idea but after being
motivated by his cellmate he agrees the
next day Kyle is set up to fight against
Valia as the battle begins Kyle gains
the upper hand and forces valia's
shoulder out of its socket in a fit of
rage Valia pulls out a knife in an
attempt to strike but he accidentally
ends up stabbing the leader of the
Russian mafia causing his demise Kyle
then uses this opportunity to smash
volia's head into a pole finally taking
him down after the fight he is escorted
Away by the guards to be killed just as
451 anticipated 451 then uses a secret
passage to access the garage where he
launches a surprise attack and kills one
of the guards meanwhile Kyle holds tolik
at gunpoint and pins him underneath a
car before taking the key to unlock his
handcuffs Kyle also retrieves his
wedding ring and disguises himself in
the guard's uniform resembling the
general he asks 451 to come with him but
the latter refuses and instead asks him
to make sure that the world knows about
this play Place following this Kyle
successfully drives away from the prison
while 451 heads to the General's office
and executes Khrushchev for his misdeeds
after this act 451 is locked back in his
cell whereas Kyle manages to return to
his home country in the final scene we
learned that krabi's corruption has been
exposed and the prison is shut down
forever subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching